history is gonna change
[Music]
i'm now for the adventures of the white
privilege boy
[Music]
ah hey there boys good to see you again
what can i do you for thanks mr
macarthur well you can start by giving
us everything in the cash register well
golly is that a firearm you're pointing
at me there yeah yeah you knew it i'm
very disappointed in you boys we don't
care empty it out yeah yeah
get out man oh i suppose boys will be
boys i'm going to have to call the
sheriff you know but you've got me for
now go ahead take everything thanks mr
mcarthur thanks pistol whip him oh all
right now that's one for you that's one
for you go ahead take some bazooka joe
and get out of here you rascals oh those
boys what pickle will they find
themselves in next stay tuned for next
week's installment of adventures of the
white privilege boys
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
stranger
[Music]
all right no sipping sound at all and
this is what happens when you replace me
with a dummy steven and then you say hey
give me a few oh
oh no
no he's i'm here you said you were going
to take a few minutes and then i this is
this was
my revenge my revenge has been spoiled
anyway my revenge will be complete
momentarily
okay all right just whatever i apologize
i apologize
i'm sorry about that guys i uh i was
gonna slip your water and everything
like i had a whole like minute and a
half i needed a little i know because we
didn't want to add extra time to the to
the start time of the show
but uh
you know we were on the road dave and i
and i i blame i blame both sonic
and uh buckies for their ghost pepper
you bought the ghost pepper beef turkey
yes then he touched himself in the
bathroom not like he's not in a bad like
that way no and the kind of thing like
you know don't use icy hot before you go
to the restroom yes
so all right don't do ghost peppers
either no i don't know i have three m
what is going on here i was gonna sip
out of one of them and i decided not can
someone come in and fix the fireplace
what's going on don't we have a show
runner in here what's happening
stop it i don't think we do
need a fire it's true we need to we need
a we need uh we need to put that up on
uh on lottoscotter.com
what does it apply jobs
all right look
we have a lot to get to dave and i were
on the road this weekend and so it was
just like drinking from a fire hose with
a weekend
let me start this off by saying
of course
everybody here
condemns mass shootings of any kind
violence of any kind and of course
racial animus of any kind hatred racial
superiority of any kind that's not hard
for us to do
i want to be really clear about that but
this week is going to be sort of an arc
because we need to deal with how the
media is misrepresenting some of these
shootings and before the bodies have
even assumed room temperature the
arguments they go to which is as
predictable as you would imagine they
are uh
gun control
and the invalid arguments that they
present there guys seriously someone
needs to turn on the fireplace here
cause when we go that long it's gonna
look like we have a dead fire they don't
have a dead fire
oh
so i want to ask you my question today
before anything else is
what do you see as the through line what
do you see as the through line here with
these shootings or many if you didn't
know this
which shootings do you know about this
weekend we all know about buffalo you
know about orange county
how much do you know about the milwauk
what happened in milwaukee
what are the similarities there are
these people all right wing racists well
seems like they're all racists but none
of them are right-wing
where am i getting that from from their
own manifesto which by the way i'm not
going to read and if you're wondering
why i'm not using names today that's
because i think it's entertaining go to
the long shot look at him crawling a
little
oh
yeah i like how you came in it and then
you're like on the way out
now i need to crawl yeah
i'm mildly ocd with this river
what's happening he turned it on with
his eyes flip the light switch on and
off 17 times otherwise dave's family
will die it's true that's not true
so uh 18. i want to ask you guys about
the throughout and i know this is one of
those sensitive topics we're going to
try and avoid showing any kind of
footage that would get us removed we're
going to try to try and not include any
content here on youtube that would get
us removed
it's always like walking on eggshells
and of course on mug club we'll be able
to uh discuss whatever it is
that we feel needs to be addressed um
unfortunately we're in a situation where
people are siloed as far as information
then they talk about how they want to
break down the silos but the left uses
this as the opportunity to say the way
to break down the silos and the echo
chambers is more regulation is more
control is more silencing of voices i
don't see how that helps so if we are
removed here on youtube or anytime this
week which i would not
would not be surprised if that happens
when we're addressing these topics uh
you can always watch us every monday
through thursday 9 00 a.m central 10 a.m
eastern on rumble over there in rumble
and of course on mug club uh where we do
an extra full 45 minutes to hour of show
lotto with credit.com club at 69 for
students veterans active military mugs
today i guess yeah well i mean you have
what's this coffee is it good
oh it's delicious coffee ah yeah did you
make it no i didn't make it no that's
probably why okay so we're gonna move on
to talk about all that but now you hear
him
you love him gerald b
no no no is gerald's back he gave me i
wish you would have been like 60 to 90
seconds late like you said so that i
could have had you know one of those
things where people say like you don't
know what you have until it's gone
i wish you were still gone
i thought you were going to say you were
still unsure what it means
i wish they'd wish they'd pave oh i wish
they'd pave you into a parking lot yeah
uh no that's
very mafia of you gerald hoffa
it just looks like han solo in the
throne
no love jail we're glad to have you back
and then of course you hear him you know
me love you can follow him on twitter at
landau dave it'll be uh oh i guess it'll
be may 29th at fuel fest in gaylord
where's gaylord gaylord's like uh two
and a half hours north of detroit oh
okay in detroit so you can go live.com
tour uh and we'll have a big fall tour
being announced but okay ahoy i didn't
give it a hold i'm sorry ahoy to your
three cup monty yes i don't know why i
have three this is a weird day free mug
monty were you still today feeling the
sonic from it we were we were we did a
gig in tulsa and by the way thank you to
everyone who came out but we decided to
make a horrible mistake and stopping at
sonic and
you bear some responsibility because you
did recommend the cheesy tots i did well
if the cheesy tots are available i'm
going to eat them yeah i know
the only problem is is uh yeah i paid
for it all day right you could have told
me that yeah i could have told you that
dang no because you're yeah because
you're like i put chili on them and i
was like i'm not going to go all the way
with ruining my whole true that's true
this coming from the man that made us
stop at white castle on a road trip i
have no one to blame but myself
this is true and dave no i would have
never said let's stop at white castle on
a road trip he did at like two in the
morning it was a great day well that's
halfway through the trip we had an
entire other half to go were you
blackout drunk
no well
not that no of course we would never say
that we were on air no we were not it's
not like we were going 145 yeah no
through the godforsaken state of
illinois because if we spin out we'll
just hit corn we'll either if you're in
illinois and you spin out you're either
going to hit corn or chicago in either
way or a prison a ghost of ty cobb yes
that's right cobb is dead yeah i okay i
can't believe it either you know what i
heard a bit of a racist i've heard that
too i don't know if it's true i have no
idea i was thinking of tex
cobb there was a there's one of those
text cap was a text i don't know okay
i was racist in the 1910s look we're
trying to bring some levity because it's
going to get a little bit heavy as we
talk about mass shootings and again it's
very very this is one thing i hope that
everyone out there you as a conservative
as a right winger as a decent human
being there's no problem in condemning
this now it's just it's very rare that
we have to condemn for example the way
islamists would have to condemn their
religion because it calls for violence
uh christians who kill in the name of
christ because it doesn't happen all
that often and if it does we go well
that guy's just not one of us it
shouldn't be you don't need to
be afraid of acknowledging evil
as though it's conceding ground it's not
it's not
buffalo shooter evil some [ __ ] hope he
rots in hell
i shouldn't say hope he will rotten hell
i don't think there's a lot of guesswork
involved there now
um
that's just sad i mean i don't know i'm
not the lord but if i were to roll the
dice if i was going to guess yeah you
could have a conversion moment i mean
yeah
it's very empty accepts the level no i
don't think so i don't think it works
quite like that
yeah sorry yeah yeah yeah yeah
i appreciate you always trying to be the
nice guy but you know what that was
stupid now
still
it's true it is true
no it's it's true but it's very unlikely
yeah unlikely yes yeah and i like to
think that it's not so
before something i also wish was untrue
and i warn you uh just for people who
are watching kids they shouldn't watch
this because this involves madonna yeah
don't watch it oh what so if you have
kids this is not a trigger warning it's
a whether it's appropriate warning three
two okay they should leave uh madonna is
releasing a new nft
uh which is the digi for people who
don't know it's the digital version of
the beanie baby scam
and
it's worse the nf tell me we were like
yeah i made a lot of money yeah so did
like five people with beanie babies and
the rest of you were left holding some
kind of a unicorn with a weird snout
it's enron without the original success
yes
so she's releasing an nft and it is well
it's pretty disgusting but it's madonna
i repeat myself
my journey through life is a
[Music]
of a woman
starting from a small seed
always pushing against the resistance of
the earth
the endless weight of gravity
scorching heat
and pouring rain
and punishing wings
i've taught myself to be subtle he needs
manscape so that i won't break well
played
while predators pick up my fruit
and scrape my bark
so off my branches
chop me down
burn me to the ground
your wish is my command
destroy my passions those are words
nor extinguish my soul my soul
first that implies she has a soul second
if you cut that uh you can gauge by the
rings how old she is it came back 162.
that's the dumbest thing i've seen it
also uh came back when you when you uh
selenium date gross yes
yes your nft is growing a tree from your
vagina yes it's really a weed yeah
it's more of a bush
more of a nuisance really yeah where's a
wood chipper when you need it so the 63
year old
defended it saying
i'm doing what women have been doing
since the beginning of time which is
giving birth now it should be noted of
course that's most women while madonna's
not primarily known for giving birth she
is recognized for being an ugly [ __ ]
now she goes on to say
but on a more existential level i'm
giving birth to art and creativity and
we would be lost without both
look uh stephen if you don't mind i need
to go cover this oh okay well yeah go
and i'll i'll yeah go go go to get ready
to prepare it because look this is the
issue here is uh not everything has to
be about
something gross and sexual this is the
problem i hope you understand like this
used to be there was a time where we
could do an entirely
clean show or even with stand-up but the
depravity in the world right now the
degeneracy i hope you see the context
we're dealing with it
without of course ever praising it or
lauding it it's disgusting she's gross
also
she's from michigan she's faking that
accent so let's um i think dave is uh
he's ready uh it's actually time to go
to we we we have some exclusive info our
newest addition on the street of street
beats
[Music]
ahoy there it's dave and i'm continuing
our street beat segment from last week
as you just saw in studio madonna had an
nft where a tree grew out of her vaginal
area what you don't know is that a real
life tree actually did and that comes
with the nfc when you purchase it this
is her real-life vaginal tree
uh
yeah it could be that one too the one
like here well it was on one of these
the streets here though let me just give
it the sniff test uh yeah
this is the tree
oh god
okay i'll go i'll try i'll try to verify
you good the breeze is coming no i'm not
drew brees but thanks for the compliment
yeah
breeze
[Music]
what's wrong what's wrong i can help you
it's gonna change again
[Music]
wow
we just decided when everyone was like
oh we can't do comedy after a mass
shooting to go another direction
also why do we have a paramedic on
retainer we should that says a lot about
us i think he was just eating are you
working live yeah are you okay no yeah
i'm not uh that was
yeah
it's the only by the way it's the only
nft that comes with a black box warning
for throat cancer
it smelled like the inside of a
pelican's beak yeah yeah she really
shouldn't do the scratch and sniff
version if if whoever buys it you're
gonna they're gonna be in a psa 20 years
from now i'm like don't do what i did
smell it
i purchased madonna's nft
no if you don't buy that please
it's most horrible thing
gosh madonna trying to stay well this is
just this is where we are
and look these here's the thing that you
need to also understand madonna goes to
the same cocktail parties as the people
in not only the entertainment
media industrial complex is a term that
i've used because it's accurate the
media and the entertainment industry are
one and the same these people know each
other it's an incestuous relationship
and they're going to pivot this is why
we'll be doing a multi-episode arc today
on not only the shooting
shootings that have taken place but the
fallout the through lines and what the
media is doing right now in tandem with
the entertainment industry and the
government to try and pivot and control
what you can do in your own life
that's what happens especially as you go
into an election season so let's hit
this first before we get to the
shootings because it does bear some
relevance now uh fauci remember fauci i
don't know if you remember him yeah yeah
oh yeah yeah yeah yeah no he's still he
still makes more than anyone here is he
releasing an nft as well yes oh good
yeah
a very small one coming out of a
different world allegedly gets uh
residuals for murder yes
you know allegedly i said allegedly a
little bit of an
i should count beagles
and that's totally real so he's trending
right now now here's the thing he's
trending and if you look on social media
they've tried to subvert the trend okay
so i'll tell first i'll show you
what the left the people in charge of
the social media the i should really
extend it entertainment media social
industrial complex toss the government
in there now too
um
they want you to believe that he's
trending because he said that he would
never serve under trump again but it's
not true but here's what's going viral
if trump were to return to the white
house as president
and covet is still a threat or there's
some other public health emergency
would you have confidence in his ability
would you have confidence in his ability
to deal with the
pandemic of of this nature would you
want to stay on in your post
i am the science
uh
well no
to the second
question you would not serve with trump
again though
fair to say right all right for sure
oh well oh man that's too bad because
he'd fire you before this it was a real
head scratch yeah yeah jim acosta at his
best folks that's journalism anthony
fountain would you say you're a fan of
trump oh
the suspense is killing me
i hope it'll last
so
this is what they're saying is trending
because they want to bury the other
report which was the initial reason for
the trend that shows that anthony fauci
along with his uh other uh i guess we
should say br scientific brethren who
haven't doctor doctor brethren doctors
who haven't seen a patient in 45 years
aids fixers getting huge yes and by that
i mean spreaders yes getting huge
kickbacks from pharmaceutical companies
again all references available at ladder
with credit.com this comes from open the
books i did some actual investigating
not like the fbi between the fiscal
years of 2010 and 2020 more than 350
million dollars in royalties
were paid by third parties to the nih
and directly to nih scientists
who are credited by the way now this is
the problem
if you were to say this it would be
consider it would be labeled
misinformation or conspiracy they credit
them as co-inventors
[Laughter]
wait wait wait so we we funded
everything correct they get credited as
a co-investment by third parties we mean
companies like major pharmaceutical
companies right right right right who
then labeled people like anthony
fountain co-inventors we don't get paid
back no no no no
they privatize profits and they
socialize losses no no you don't get any
revenue from whatever these companies
and anthony faucini uh
anthony fauci received for this vaccine
but you do get to foot the 40 billion
dollar bill to uh ukraine while your
baby starves so there you go isn't that
wonderful now why is it an estimate
in this study because the documents are
unbelie they're heavily redacted yeah so
let me just tell you what we do know we
don't know the amount of money well you
do know the number of payouts yeah so
anthony fauci received anyone want to
take a guess how many payouts from third
parties like pharmaceutical companies i
think one would be too many yeah five
one would be 20. 23. oh good 23 royalty
payments that's more than i've gotten
for the arthur christmas special
that's fair though yeah that is fair i
should get nothing
no yeah that is too many on both your
parts yes it's too many certainly for
fauci when you consider the fact that
he's suckling at the taxpayer's teat and
he gets 450 plus thousand dollars a year
as a salary so that plus 23 royalty
payments hey we're going to be talking a
little bit about how the fbi is running
some investigations after the shootings
to figure out the motive oh um
where's the investigation here i know
it's redacted for us anyone there cia
fbi any anyone going to be doing doj can
anyone do an investigation as to where
these payments are coming from does
conflict of interest exist for lifetime
government employees
i'm still trying to figure out how this
is not just work product and that the
company that you work for you know the
government the taxpayers that foot the
bill don't get the rewards completely of
what you've produced right i thought you
got a salary to produce these things
right i'm just unclear on i guess the
rules of making more money than well he
doesn't get a salary to produce anything
he gets a salary to monitor he shouldn't
be getting any company well and throw
out any pitches i mean yes but isn't
this
if your profit it's profiteering with
our money correct uh i mean it's just
illegal yeah general malfeasance
yeah so this could make sure yeah but if
we're gonna do that i'm not a lawyer
aren't we all but it's grumpy yeah is
there a little bit of a trickle down
yeah
and so what i'm supposed to believe is
that this comes out and that that really
cringe reporting by jim acosta is what's
going viral on the internet because it's
like oh he laughed and said no yeah
exactly what it is in other words
there's a scandal that actually affects
everybody that most americans would be
upset about if you saw this on social
media that starts trending and then what
gets injected and what starts hitting
the top of the trends him saying i i
wouldn't serve again under trump well
that's that's earth shot this is the
news that we need to know i had no idea
about it yeah he's like of course i
wouldn't it was my job to get him out
in other words the media's job right is
to inform us particularly inform us of
issues that are important
this is why there is no trust in
american institutions there should be no
trust in the institution of government
there should be no trust in the
institution of the fbi i'll get to that
in a second there should be no trust in
the nih
it's been destroyed because of you and
the media's job
once upon a time or at least what we
believed it to be it never really has
been this is to inform the public
particularly if it is information that
affects them and it's information that
the public does not yet already have so
let's just let's weigh this
what would be the media's job
letting you know that fauci doesn't
really like donald trump or finding out
that anthony fauci has received 23
royalty payments
from third parties including
pharmaceutical companies which one did
you know which one do you think is more
relevant considering that
dr anthony fauci was the catalyst for
locking down the economy and creating
record unemployment and businesses
shuttering if the media's job is to give
is to shine a light on information that
you should know i can't think of
something more relevant instead they're
actually actively providing cover and
then they blame you for not trusting
them
so let's go doctor yes doctor
yeah
he's
just like the kind of guy who's a doctor
has a doctorate in philosophy and makes
you call him doctor you're like i'm not
going to do that no no yeah it's like a
chiropractor next to a dollar tree right
yes exactly
let me guess let me go in uh mr doctor
chiropractor but what's uh let me put it
what's wrong oh my back needs cracking
who could have guessed that one oh and i
have to come back forever really
right hey how did you figure out what's
wrong with my back you didn't even i
mean you didn't even do like an mri
that's like fixing a car without looking
under the hood oh you're a lying person
i see
well go ahead touch my spine i won't
need it yes exactly
just torque it any which way it's not a
sensitive sooner or later i'm sure
you'll do something right there's one
chiropractor right now like hey i used
to watch you guys and it's okay leave i
am unsubscribing though i'm very serious
about what i do yes well guess what
nobody else's
[Laughter]
are you saying that chiropractors aren't
real doctors yes correct that's exactly
what i'm saying ouch so let's go here to
the mass shootings that had taken place
over the weekend i don't know is anyone
here
you disagree i don't think anyone here
disagrees oh no i'll go to a
chiropractor but i'm not sure like but
i'm doctor i'm like let's take it easy
yes i know there's a chance i'm not
walking out yes exactly yeah i mean
you're walking with the risk funnily
yeah good news your neck doesn't hurt
but uh your legs those ain't moving
anymore yeah yes that's done too well
usually we up charge that we call it the
christopher reeves package but oh
you know what i'm just gonna let i'm
gonna call this one a freebie roll away
superman yeah you said you wanted to be
superman we have a punch card
six uh adjustments and the seventh
paralysis is free
so let's go to the mass shootings which
is what well and i say that
and here's the thing if i were talking
on cnn right now and we've been covering
or watching cnn this morning
people would say shootings
plural yeah because they've only covered
one
now of course all mass shootings are
horrible they're all evil and the people
who commit them are evil and we
acknowledge that there is good and evil
in this world that's why i believe in a
limited government limited centralized
power because i believe that human
beings are inherently selfish and
selfishness is a form of evil now over
the weekend there were a number of mass
shootings okay uh but
the chances are if you're watching any
you've only been hearing about one
another hate crime at a grocery store
those words shouldn't even compute they
shouldn't fit in the same sentence a
hate crime at a grocery store is it you
and the serials
buffalo residents in a predominantly
black neighborhood who were just trying
to take care of their families when a
white gunman opened fire on saturday
killing 10 people and injuring three
others
all the evidence so far suggests that
this young man this suspect just 18
years old
was poisoned by lies and bs from online
message boards we want to thank you for
joining us tonight as we continue our
coverage of the tragedy at tops i'm
claudine ewing chase i can tell you that
there have been prayer rallies food
giveaways cookouts here all day today as
this community in buffalo continues to
mourn the loss of those 10 lives
meantime at the tops grocery store
behind me it means there's no active
scene as that investigation that mass
shooting wraps up its first full day is
there an ongoing threat are your
residents safe today
uh i think the question that we need to
ask ourselves
are
any residents
safe in this country
anywhere
we have to focus
on sensible gun control
ow there it is he went there you know
what he also said
hate speech has to be outlawed on online
platforms so didn't define what sensible
gun control was and didn't define what
hate speech was but answered just about
every question that was the mayor by the
way yes yeah doing that also an idiot
yeah
he's like this is the point why don't we
all rally can't we all come together and
no no we can't we can't all come
together under the guise of
matching evil with more evil gandhi said
of all the evil i think the exact quote
someone can fact check me i'm getting
pretty close to it was of all
the evil acts or all the dark acts
committed by the british empire robbing
a nation of arms will be known as its
blackest this was from gandhi folks so
the idea that we match evil and by the
way let's just be clear we completely
condemn the shooter as evil and a racist
100 but matching it with the evil
of disarming
a populist to turn them into sitting
ducks is not something where we can hold
hold hands and sing kumbaya and i'm not
going to fake it no i'm not going to
fake it now
this man the shooter and i'm not going
to give you his name
uh he also declared himself to be a
former communist who then said that he
turned into a left-wing authoritarian
these are his words
just to be
clear that's not being reported let me
read you how he describes it he says
when i was 12 i was deeply into
communist ideology talk to anyone from
my old high school and ask about me and
you will hear that from age 15 to 18
however i consistently moved farther to
the right in a political compass i fall
in the middle of the mild moderate
authoritarian left category
and i would prefer to be called a
populist so here's the thing
uh okay
racist got it left wing authoritarian ra
the media wants you to believe that only
right wing can be racist why because
they somehow describe
racism as being right wing it's a
beautiful it's a beautiful trick that
they play with words where could we
where could we find examples because
people will act as those who shocking
that we're trying to do the mental
gymnastics that amber heard is doing
understand no no are there have there
historically been any left-wing racist
authoritarians i don't know hitler mao
che which is why we have that shirt
not only were they well-known leftists
well-known authoritarians
they were self-avowed racists all of
them i mean just there we just went
through
i don't know what nine figures of people
who were killed in the name of
left-left-wing authoritarian ideology
so don't act like this is a surprise
this is a surprise the only reason
people think some i can hear some people
saying oh hitler was right-wing no no
you only believe it was right-wing
because the left has told you that
racism is right-wing look at what he
wanted he thought that socialism would
work national socialist workers party of
germany so long as it only involved
white people
that's a terrible acronym for nazi
well my pen just oh man where'd it go go
ahead of all the trees
you know what you're going to hear most
people say is i started moving further
to the right they're going to cut the
quote off right there and you've already
started seeing that it's like oh he
started moving further to the right so
that must mean all of the fox news
tucker carlson thing right that's got to
be what happened right yeah well that's
what they're trying to do now let me
also be clear um
i'm not a conspiracy theorist
okay and not saying anything is
not implying whatsoever falls flat none
of that nope just to be clear what i am
saying though is there were many
shootings there were multiple shootings
that took place over the course of this
weekend and that happens every week
every weekend the media does have
selection bias where they can pick
whichever one they want to thrust into
the spotlight and hit you with a
narrative that's what i'm saying now
that being said
if you look at the manifesto
it doesn't pass the sniff test let me
give you some examples as to why he says
that he was radicalized
by the christ church shooter usually
shooters don't say i was radicalized by
insert it here it reads like something a
liberal would write to say that a right
winger was radicalized someone who
commits a mass shooting doesn't believe
that they are radicalized they believe
that they are rational yeah look at the
columbine shooters they didn't say we
were radicalized by they just said yeah
we really liked natural born killers in
the matrix this then it was tip or gore
those people who say radicalized this
looks like it was written by someone
like a tip or gore i was radicalized by
i'm sorry
sorry
this is just this is just my opinion
reads like [ __ ] yeah i don't know i
don't know of anybody who says that
right because you're going out to take
care of what you think is a problem that
needs to be fixed not a supposed problem
and i'm a radical now and i have to go
and do something that doesn't need to be
done but since i'm a radical i'm going
to do it right right
yeah real insane people don't know
they're crazy right that doesn't make
any sense to me has anybody looked into
like how this could have been
manipulated like the manifesto that was
put out yet because i know i don't know
if anyone has but i will say it's a very
misogynistic manifesto i really prefer a
more inclusive one yes exactly if
anything his greatest crime is a
manifesto it doesn't include there's not
enough diversity no that's my problem
with it i prefer he him i don't even
know his pronoun i don't know his
pronouns and i don't know his opinions
on title ix nope
i could care less so look he did they
they read you this from the manifesto in
the selection bias that he did pick an
area with a high percentage of black
people that was also close because he
was a lazy shooter
uh and um what they don't include is
something else that is important
okay so here's the thing they're a
racist yes
you can never stop people from being
racist again the media's job here
is to say what information can we
provide you that might allow you to be
more informed that might allow you to be
more capable or more
alert for situations like this in the
future
well there's other information that's
relevant i don't know if you've heard
this again comment below
and by the way if you want to stick it
to media
share this show right now that's the
best thing you can do on on on youtube
because the likes don't matter as much
since they've gotten rid of the dislike
button
uh sharing is caring
he wrote
plus new york has heavy gun laws
so it would ease me if i knew that any
legally armed civilian was limited to 10
round magazines or cucked firearms yeah
is what he wrote this is what the
governor of new york was talking about
she went there and said now he was he
legally owned this rifle but he probably
went across the border to pennsylvania
to get a magazine with a larger capacity
yeah that was the focus on all of this
and i understand you're saying okay if
he has more ammunition
how about a good guy with a gun how
about having more relaxed laws that
allow people to protect themselves that
way guy comes walking up with a gun bang
good guy with a gun stops it saves the
day and there's a parade yeah how about
that and also 10 people dead and i can
hear people saying oh you really think
that you're going to be you're going to
be the rifleman yes look the statistics
are 12 to 20 something thousand
homicides with a gun each year in the
united states according to the fbi doj
every crime statistic we have it's
minimum 500 000 up to 3 million likely
two and a half defensive uses of
firearms each year don't want to hear
you say if it saves one life you're
willing you're willing to end over two
million there are far more lives in this
country saved through firearms than
taken and by the way the people who take
lives with firearms just like in this
manifesto i will read it to you again he
says
that he would be upset or worried if he
knew that there was any legally armed
civilian
basically with more than 10 round
magazines so in other words if you're
saying okay we have a motive but what is
the how
how we carried it out the how we see
this time and time and time and time and
time again
i'm going to go into an area where i
know
people are not armed where i know that
people can't defend themselves that's
relevant information you can't stop
being black
there will be racists you can't stop
being brothers oh that's michael jackson
you can't stop
you can't stop being white
people are going to try and commit acts
of evil but you can't stop yourself from
being a sitting duck yeah
well it gives you it gives you a chance
i mean there's no denying that it gives
somebody a chance a it's 100 better than
having nothing right and putting up a
sign with a gun on it with a circle and
an you know line over it is not stopping
anyone and that's literally what they do
yeah right and this is tragic and
disgusting like i could barely like i
read it before a show
and it just messed with my head because
i i just find it so disgusting that this
can even happen right that anybody would
do this live streaming it everything
it's disgraceful unbelievable and you're
right it's
people have to be able to protect
themselves now because the lunacy is
gone off the rails well the lunacy has
gone off the rails in the sense that
they stream it as far as violent crime
before covet it was going down and now
of course we've seen it go up of course
and who was the president uh before
coven when it was going down apparently
the most racist i don't know if we
mentioned him we might be removed here
from youtube so we're still on rumble
now what does the left do
most people react like mr landau here
most people react like we do here in the
studio most people react like you do at
home think that it's disgusting and say
okay what is it that we can do what
actions can we take to make
make ourselves safer to protect our
families what does the left do well they
blame tucker carlson
and they claim it's because he uh
promoted the white replacement theory so
let's look at the tweets lincoln project
co-founder and uh professional [ __ ]
rick wilson tweeted the buffalo killer's
manifesto reads like a job application
for a junior producer on tucker carlson
and no i'm not being flippant yeah yeah
junior producer tucker carlson i'm sure
would be uh would be arden supporters of
gun control uh the lincoln project the
the people with the the pedophilia
claims is that yes they're still around
they're still allowed to have a voice in
this well we don't know the details we
don't know the details we don't know all
of the details no we just know that it's
obviously something yes yeah but that's
it yeah but by something we mean
pedophilia yeah by pedophilia yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah we don't know all the
other details
yeah i would say that's enough
but that's just me
no but it turns out it's just so much
more rampant than yeah we ever thought
it turns out that it's almost in every
nook and cranny yeah it's like you if
you go to lincoln project and you play
the game like spot
the portion of lincoln product that has
not been destroyed by rampant pedophilia
and you have to switch it and then play
okay spot the part that actually still
exists despite rampant pedophilia and
the answer is zero there's really
nothing there both both times so
brooklyn dad
uh who's known on twitter and only
twitter went after carlson saying tucker
carlson frequently pushes the white
replacement theory that the buffalo mass
murderer cited in his manifesto carlson
fox news they have blood on their hands
and as always the occupy democrats still
clinging to that relevancy remember
they tweeted breaking the fbi announces
that they're investigating today's mass
shooting in buffalo as quote racially
motivated violent extremism wait the fbi
is investigating it
hmm
what what
oh you're useless
i was gonna
okay so the fbi going oh we read his
manifesto well he says he's doing it
because uh he hates black people we're
going to spend millions of taxpayer
dollars to get to the bottom of this no
no let's uh let's investigate like he
really does i hope this case doesn't go
cold we only have 48 hours no no no he's
he's saying that he did it because he's
a racist left-wing authoritarian shut up
johnson you bumpkin local police this is
now federal takeover
this is the fbi what is this man trying
to say he has red threads it's like he's
saying i hate black people and gun and
i'm pro gun control can't be that simple
put it in the jfk half a pile yes
i believe they're connected yeah also
the john travolta posters that one still
puzzles me yes no no hold on a second he
wrote he told you exactly why he did it
shut up johnson you local deputy bumpkin
hick worthless piece of crap did you
read it shut up shut up
this vexes me it shouldn't i can't read
we've gotta we've got a bunch of drunken
hooligans to frame is kidnapping a
governor what do you think like this is
the fbi is useless
this is them afterwards trying to come
in and take well we're running an
investigation
the job of the government is very
limited i'm not an anarchist one of
their legitimate jobs is to serve to
protect the people both from external
and internal threats that's one of the
only legitimate purviews of government
and they failed and afterward the fbi is
trying to say well look we're going to
figure this out and we'll get you a
report on monday that will be entirely
useless also by the way the fbi i think
they did investigate this guy and they
missed it
well that's a first
well there was another quote there what
was the other quote from the shooter
left a manifesto setting tucker
carlson's white replacement theory as
his motive and by the way occupied
democrats then say retweet if you think
that tucker carlson must be investigated
oh and then let me guess you're going to
accuse us yeah you're going to accuse me
of profiting off of this death
by the way do you know what white the
replacement theory that they're talking
about i saw again jim acosta intrepid i
can hear him getting incredible he
showed some stuff that really made drove
the point home he said
it's the immigration thing it's the
illegal immigration and bringing in
voters to vote democrat we've that's
been something that's been talked about
for a long time it's not black people
though right he's not saying blackbeard
if tucker carlson was out there saying
they're replacing white people with
black people
then maybe they could try and string
these things together but it's two
different groups of people this guy
wasn't going after a place that had a
taqueria in it right right that wasn't
his aim he was going after a place with
a lot of black people he was a racist
yes becker carlson is not a racist
that i've heard by the way
i also think all investigation should be
based on retweets i've always of course
yes yes no it's the basis of any good
investigation that's i've always said it
well does he have a garage pool in his
in his home that needs to be
investigated fbi maybe send 10 agents
for that one yeah maybe there's a
there's a there's a cord with a loop hey
i hear there's a poop swastika somewhere
in a stanford bathroom how would you get
on that i saw a banana peel that was
also left somewhere in a tree oh by the
way that one us remember the fbi guy
yeah the fbi guy who was who was
stringing us along a little bit trying
to get us to buy body armor that was
only available to uh to officers and
we're like no we'll just buy uh from
spartanburg just by civilian stuff then
he disappeared and found out that he was
part of that plot to kidnap governor
whitmer we've been the subject of it we
just don't do a sting because we're like
well that's part and parcel do you have
any idea how many times a day i get sued
i don't give a [ __ ]
now
forgive the language i'm a little angry
today and by the way the left doesn't
have a monopoly on anger they just wanna
they wanna have this monopoly in
righteous indonesian because we hate
guns yeah you know what i hate evil and
i hate lies well they have a monopoly on
explosive unjustified anger yes that's
true yeah on the monopoly on billions of
dollars in community damages and
overreaction yes
so uh also acting like the white
replacement theory from tucker carlson
um
is just this invention from tucker
carlson is ridiculous they they say it
on the left they just they called it
quote this is from vox the browning of
america now see that seems like i'm
doing a reverse sear on a steak that's
weird
i don't think that's the same thing no
it's not the same thing that's what it
sounds like it sounds like it sounds
delicious reverse sear is the best
method to do it is fake if you don't you
do in the oven you get a temperature and
then this
and you're done yeah that being said uh
you know what our country is not going
to do well this is the issue and it's
okay they want you to feel guilty this
is what they do they take the most
horrifying thing they want to copy they
want to attach it to something that you
agree with
most you know who agrees with by the way
the problem
of demographics in the united states and
open borders black people look at the
polling data they're not big fans of it
the idea that people can come into this
country illegally and then be voters for
all time
and live on the public dole that's a
problem
and you can still say that's a problem
because black people acknowledge that
it's a problem they have a pro and it
doesn't mean that you support mass
shooters this is what they're trying to
do don't allow them to do it so if
someone says you have blood on your
hands just say you first
you first how about that you have blood
on your hands because you would support
policies that would result in millions
of more deaths per year because of a
defenseless populace and by the way
you've created racial division in this
country with billions of dollars in
damages and you've divided and conquered
us through race
gender i guess gender sex orientation
whatever the hell it is today i don't
know how many genders are i don't care
the point is how
who's fracturing us just use the gender
as an example what do i believe there's
two you say 57.
and then demand that we unite
yeah what's amazing how they just taste
something so tragic and instantaneously
turn it into more division right that's
what bothers me the most it it
immediately becomes black and white and
it's print just printed in black and
white about black and white to divide us
more to get us angry at each other and
it's just frustrating at this point yep
and that you know what the problem is
they'll say oh you're playing into it no
i'm not i'm sorry if you guys do this
because you try and push gun control
right after
it's it's all right we're divided then
there's no kumbaya moment sorry well
you're not even specific about what you
want show me the laws that you in an act
right now if you want to tweet it's
common sense gun reform show me the laws
you in an act right now that would stop
this
show me just show me exactly what you're
saying because i know where it ends it's
confiscation yeah it's making sure that
nobody can own firearms
i understand where you're going so let's
not couch it in common sense gun reform
that everybody agrees on because we
don't agree on it yes there's nothing
more common sense than that's legal
that's illegal what is that the only
legal illegal what the angle of the grip
it's common sense well it looks like a
weapon of war stephen yeah no if it's
brown it's legal if it's black illegal
what's common sense you need not concern
yourself with this technical terminology
how about go screw yourself is that well
you know what uh i would say that's
uncommon sense so i hate to say it is a
weapon of war
that's the point that's every weapon
exactly why would that that's why they
weren't invented
like did you use a weapon of war to no
no i use the acme gun that a white flag
comes out and says bang you know the
guns that the french use yeah i tend to
draw a tunnel hole in the wall and he
runs right into it every time right
exactly i used my wild stallion's make
piece guitar yes every now and then i
hit a button and an anvil falls yes
that's still possible can i get a mace
maybe yeah we need a law in the book
it's an acme gun it's not it's not war
yeah it's a war it's a gun of comedy so
of course former vice president joe
biden uh announced that he's going to be
visiting buffalo in the wake of the
shooting which look i understand why
wouldn't why wouldn't uh sitting former
vice president yeah visit the site of a
national uh tragedy like this
um
oh wait wasn't what happened remember
with wakasha when people were mowed down
and he it was a black supremacist
murdered parade goers to push vaccines
joe biden oh he sent his wife ah
couldn't find the time then she too is a
doctor he must have sent her to provide
urgent medical care
unbelievable
so there's an obvious double standard
between yes doctor between buffalo you
know what let's uh let's just uh create
a choking hazard with dave and let's see
if she comes in and performs cpr dave
i'm sorry you'll die i don't want to do
that
i'll do it on myself i'll break my own
ribs hey look at this really quickly can
we pull cnn up three yeah let's pull the
end look at this so this is what i want
you to understand
chicago
atlanta
los angeles yeah
new york these things are happening all
over the place they want you to focus on
the ones that they can get political hay
out of hey cnn you you care about you
care about black people right we all
care about black people
how can they help protect themselves
better well there's a staggering amount
of crime
being committed against black people by
black people they are far more likely to
be shot and to be killed by other black
people not statistically it's not even
close if you want to help them provide
them with the actionable information
but you don't so there's an obvious
double standard between buffalo and
waukesha
clear racial motive uh in the waukesha
parade murders by the way i condemn both
do i i need to keep saying buffalo
racism waukesha racism they are both
absolutely disgusting we even covered
this by the way the waukesha murders on
the show back then
i'm going to bring to you the criminal
record and what this man daryl brooks jr
who mowed down women and children i
don't know what the death toll is up to
now last i checked it was
it was five maybe six and there are kids
in critical condition he's been charged
with 11 crimes going back to 1999. so
let's go to a social media post because
people are saying we don't know anything
about his motivation yeah now again i
ask you what if math boy what if
daryl brooks jr
was white
well here we go we know exactly what it
would be it's it's as close to an a b
comparison as you can get as far as
manifestos as far as motive the only
thing is
different mechanism a vehicle which by
the way kills far far far more people
than firearms in any given year in any
country
uh let's read the headlines back then
with the walker shooter because you just
heard them on scene and say white
shooter so this was wisconsin five dead
after
car plows into waukesha christmas parade
npr government-funded news five people
are dead and 40 injured after a driver
speeds through a wisconsin parade an abc
affiliate at least 40 injured five
killed as suv drives into holiday parade
well well that's a that's that's a
that's a vindictive suv yeah it's like
an angry suv herbie
very racist suv yes we couldn't believe
it by the way it's like you don't have
to divine this guys this doesn't take
like deep diving research you can
quickly figure out it's like a guy walks
in and shouts allahu akbar and blows
himself i'm like we're just puzzled we
have no idea
why that happened weird
i don't even know who this akbar guy is
i have no idea uh well what's what
happened there's this confession no well
we don't need to deal with that yeah but
a white guy commits any crime
and it's obviously white supremacy
racism in this case it was white
supremacy no in this case it's true
right but every other time a white guy
commits a crime they go they run with
racism immediately and then they have to
come back and so it rings hollow so it
rings hollow so yeah so the the you know
the few people
by that i mean the cnn viewer who
actually believes now they go oh so it
was another white supremacy killing
no no it wasn't this is the first one
well i've been hearing that there have
been so many white supremacy yeah it's
not a thing this is this is this is a
rarity so what do you do it's just like
when people come out and they say me to
me to me to me too because they had a
bad date what does it do it dilutes the
horrible crime of rape and people who
are the actual victims of it it's the
same thing white supremacist violent
crimes and murders in this country are
incredibly rare but the media covers
them as common and so when it actually
happens we're able to address it and
condemn it it just happens so rarely so
waukesha this was a black supremacist
this was someone who believed that white
people were inferior that's why he
targeted them including children here's
how former vice president addressed the
waukesha situation well we don't have
all the facts and details yet we had a
lot of money this morning
that five families in waukesha
are facing fresh grief
of a life without a loved one
at least 40 americans are suffering from
injuries
some of them in critical condition now i
would have no problem with that if he
didn't lie on the outside saying we
don't have a lot of details yeah we did
i guess the fbi didn't run their
investigation at that point here's how
he spoke of the buffalo shooting let me
say a word
about yesterday's mass shooting in
buffalo new york
a lone gunman
armed with weapons of war and hate
phil's soul
shot and killed 10 innocent people in
cold blood
at a grocery store
on saturday afternoon
jill and i
like all of you pray for the victims
and their families
and a devastated community
i've been receiving updates from my team
in the white house
that's in close contact with the justice
department
we're still gathering the facts
but already
the justice department has stated
publicly that is investigating the
matter
as a hate crime
racially motivated act of white
supremacy and violent extremism
wow right away right away
now just so you know that's the
president dividing everyone yeah
immediately former vice president yes
surprise
foreign yeah respect you don't have to
like the man but you respect the office
the office of dementia the office of
former vice presidency of vice
presidents well and just in case you're
not pissed off enough already uh i was
watching meet the press on sunday and
they had al sharpton in this panel and
he said well he misread prompter well
pretty much he said is it any is it any
wonder and i'm just you know
paraphrasing what he said is any wonder
that we have a rise in these crimes we
had a pr we had a racist president who
said that there were good people on both
sides yeah just parroting the same
issues and everybody nodded along as
though that's
what drives this and then uh reverend
sharpton said a prayer
for buffalo
well and he said
it happened at cops
it's tops tops what you like
no no no it's tops you mean like the
card that fouchy yes sorry fauci put his
name on
i would like to issue a prior
prayer for the people of buffalo due to
this horrible
quit
supremacy
chuck todd cut from him many times
let's go back to you jim acosta
got an alligator on his t-shirt
can we get him an earpiece he he is
wearing an airplane yeah he can't he
doesn't hear any hairpiece
no but they're pushing that same
narrative it's not that they're just
saying oh racist racist racist saying no
this is from president donald trump he
was a racist he said racist things
everybody who watches fox news is a
republican right now they are racist
every white person in america you're
racist that's what they're spewing and
that's what i'm pushing back on you want
this guy was racist you want to take
away women you want to control women's
bodies donald trump was a racist donald
trump was calling for violence therefore
you should be ashamed to be pro-life
don't speak up unless you want to be
guilty of hate speak don't speak up if
you voted for donald trump unless you
want to be guilty of hate speak oh and
what are we seeing today well not are we
seeing a department of misinformation
with our federal government which should
cause your testicles to retract into
their body cavity
um we are also dealing
with them now calling for more
censorship calling for more uh more
regulation
online of people speaking now that also
includes tucker carlson that includes
they want you to be ashamed of your
opinion when your opinion is nothing
shameful
i'm willing to bet if you're watching
this right now you think racism is ridic
it's silly it's stupid it's ridiculous
and it should play no role in our
politics
from the left or the extremely rare
instances of actual neo-nazis on the
right i want to bet that your opinion is
awful and this manifesto is
gut-wrenchingly terrible yeah and so was
waukesha
but they want you to be ashamed of your
opinion because it might include the
right to protect yourself it might
include not allowing abortion all the
way up until including birth period you
should be ashamed and you should remain
silent and if you don't well the
entertainment social media slash
traditional media slash government
industrial complex is going to find a
way to silence you so let's also speak
of silence what else have they been
silent on ignoring uh i don't know a few
other mass shootings
that ta that have taken place
do you guys know this did you guys know
about the orange county shooting
gunman killed one injured five i did but
yeah at a church center yeah but you're
in you're in for
yeah
i know the screen i shouldn't answer as
if you're speaking no it's okay it's
okay because i know that you know
it was rhetorical
i've been watching cnn this whole time
they haven't mentioned it in the last i
guess three hours well i don't want yeah
no yeah well they don't mention anything
unless it's completely no they've and
they've mentioned buffalo new york which
that's fine i want you to talk about
this because i want people to see what
racism really looks like yes i get it
right i want that i want that out there
so that you can see it and go hop racism
nope we don't and that race
black people hope that they can't be
armed exactly that's relevant i want you
to see that but i also want you to see
this other one i want you to see orange
county right it's not there now the
suspect's race uh in orange county again
shot up a church only mentioned on cnn
in paragraph five says police police
have a suspect in custody he is believed
to be an asian man in his 60s who
doesn't live in the area uh i'm not
going to show up because it's very
clearly an asian man
it is believed that he does he identify
as agent asian is that what you're
saying right now john wayne gacy is
believed to carry with him clown makeup
and astro huh we're not we found both
but we're not sure if that's a hundred
percent accurate he thought his uh porch
was a graveyard right underneath ah yes
now it is believed that john when gacy
would dress up like uh a clown put on
the makeup and rape cub scouts and we
only believe that because he did it and
had it had it written down and notarized
oh bragged a bit the notorious but we
don't want to confirm it yet bit of a
show i want to leave
milwaukee friday night 17 people were
injured in a mass shooting now on this
one we don't this is this is just me
making a bet
it says 10 people have been taken into
custody so far and 10 guns have been
recovered all the shooting victims are
expected to survive no race mentioned ah
interesting wasn't that after the bucks
game in milwaukee right near that area
and thousands of things i don't follow
sports but i believe no i'm just saying
you've tied this into a anytime
something like this ties into like a
social event it's for some reason people
seem to care a little bit more right
it's like milwaukee bucks the nba
playoffs this happens right outside
there's thousands of fan out there fans
out there it tends to get out in the
bloodstream a lot faster i'm not really
hearing a whole another great shot and
by the way also this asian man i won't
give you his name but believed to be
asian and by that i mean absolutely
asian the church he shot up should we
know it was like a taiwanese church will
in a bet
if the guy had a vendetta against the
could be you know could
could maybe be chinese or just a super
fan of john cena just well just the
statement of believed to be asian is one
of the dumbest things i've ever read
yeah we believe he may have been we
don't want to miss
one
yeah
we have to wait until the fbi
investigation is complete you mean
they're doing one not on this no
he he was holding his fingers like this
the whole time even in cuffs i i'm not
sure if he was joking we believe he was
asian because he took the police on a
two-hour very slow chase yes it's
breakfast at tiffany's but uh you know
we're not sure he drove a toyota van uh
down the white line in the middle yes
the freeway yes
and put a student driver sticker on his
bumper to throw us off but didn't work
did not work we have the finest working
on it did not have my dry cleaning ready
uh
so what else do i well houston two
people were killed
two people were killed and used another
three hospitalized after shooting uh at
a flea market in houston says
investigators believe one of the people
hospitalized was among those who opened
fire and two more suspected shooters
were detained at the scene
sheriff's deputy told uh h sorry ktrk tv
no mention of race here either
oh then if there's no mention that means
you must not know gonna be an
investigation can't possibly know based
on photos you don't live in a free
country you don't live in a country with
the rule of law just because you have
laws are the laws applied equally are
the investigations conducted
equally
if it's not then guess what the fbi the
doj the cia they're no longer
in service of the people
they are now political propagandists
and hit men thugs
lowlifes
if they are not if the fbi is not
investigating every single one of these
then the fbi serves no purpose the fbi
again it's selection bias you don't need
to believe in some conspiracy of false
flags or george soros you know getting
people together and teaching them how to
use a firearm you just need to
understand human nature that the media
leans very very hard left and so does
all of social media and so does this
white house that they work in tandem and
that they are able to select the stories
and select which criminals get the
investigations and which ones are
publicized because they want you to be
ashamed of what you believe
don't
you don't believe that people should be
murdered period let alone because of
their race do not if there's nothing
else that you get from this show and
tomorrow we're going to do a segment on
gun control
because they do this before the bodies
are
even cult
you get nothing else from the show don't
allow anyone to make you ashamed of
something that you don't believe that's
what's happening
and they don't look the media again they
could they could help with black deaths
in this country this is when people say
that we're we're racist because we point
out crime statistics well okay hold on a
second it can actually help people from
being murdered particularly black people
i don't want to see more murdered black
people why isn't the media talking about
that nationally black people four times
more likely to be killed by a firearm
than the general population
and by the way 2021 out of over a
thousand 81 percent were black
in this study that matters
if you care about protecting lives if
you care particularly about black
americans and not just when it comes
time to vote
which by the way you also know the fact
that most black people support having
some kind of identification to vote
then you need to let them know
what the risks are
would a doc would a doctor be serving a
black person well if he doesn't mention
to them sickle cell
because it could because it is something
that is almost entirely exclusive to a
race of people it's a concern they need
to be aware about
but it could is it racist
is it racist for
the fbi for the deal to say look if
you're black you're far more likely to
be shot than a white person and that's
likely to come from another black person
in your neighborhood
well that changes the approach that
changes how we fix it all of a sudden
the fbi doesn't just need to be
investigating some left-wing
authoritarian random lone gunman shooter
we say what can we do to actually change
these statistics
it's actionable information
if the media isn't giving you actionable
information
the media is not doing its job and it
serves again like the fbi like this
useless former vice president
like the doj
like the department of misinformation it
serves no
purpose they can blame donald trump as
they are not only for racism but for
sowing mistrust in the institutions
which institutions well government well
the media
well our crime bureaus guess what that's
not donald trump's fault
it's their fault it's your fault if you
want to know why people don't trust you
it's because when people are dying and
you don't give them the actual
information and you don't give them
something that can help them to avoid
dying in the future you have now failed
to fulfill
your original purpose you are not
protecting the people and i will go one
step further say you were actively
hurting them
actively hurting them like amber heard
does johnny depp which we just have some
breaking uh on this and we always have
to be careful with it i don't know if we
if you guys wanted to say it but i think
we could just go to mug club right now
let's just do that to be safe all right
you know what because i'm because i have
so many manifestos that i can they're
not shooter manifestos no no no
different they're actually they're
really more yelp reviews well those are
kind of the same regarding sonic most
manifestos for yelp are far more hateful
than any white supremacist manifesto
i've ever read especially if they've
just eaten sonic i mean what kind of
sick bastard rights he helped review i
know it takes the time to write a
negative review about mcdonald's so
we're going to read some of these yelp
reviews you can call them manifestos i
call them manifestos if you're watching
here on youtube we've got another 45
minutes to an hour smash the like button
leave a comment and tomorrow we are
going to cover gun control so you can
you know what piss off youtube piss off
do
[Music]